alors Wars c'est une histoire incroyable de
gens qui trouvent leur place dans un monde
ces personnages leur vie bien
qu'ils soient dans une galaxie très lointaine c'est un
voyage auquel les gens peuvent s'identifier Je me sens
honoré d'avoir été autorisé à
continuer le voyage caméra  action ce qui
arrive à ces personnages que nous connaissons
et aimons c'est un monde dans lequel je veux
revenir immédiatement la magie de Star Wars
ça vous coupe le souffle et c'est
quelque chose que George Lucas a commencé et
nous portons définitivement celui que j'ai
été  un fan de Star Wars en tant qu'adulte et
enfant, je veux dire que c'est fou, il
suffit de regarder autour de moi oh mon dieu oh mon dieu
chaque personne qui est venue au
projet a été un grand fan de Star Wars
Je tremble littéralement comme si c'était
fou c'est ça
groupe intergénérationnel de personnes qui apportent toutes
ces sensibilités à la réalisation de
ce film, il est ici
Chewie nous sommes à la maison cette partie de mon
voyage Star Wars est assez différente maintenant
parce que maintenant je me sens partie de la famille que
nous sommes  revenant à ces histoires que les
gens ressentent intensément pour
[Musique]
vous